[Music]
in our weekend flash sale you'll get 12
weeks of the magazine
in print and online for just 12 pounds
and we'll also send you a bottle of
johnny walker black label
scotch whiskey to become a subscriber
today go to spectator dot co dot uk
slash flash sale brexit
the clock continues to tick down to
december the 31st
that's when the transition period to
leave the eu ends
only two weeks though until the eu's
december summit
and that's the latest time any deal can
be struck well
probably probably not sensible to be too
definitive about this these days
we know how the negotiators like to push
things to the last minute let's go and
mark our car who knows all about this
i'm joined by ivan rogers
you work closely with david cameron and
theresa may
on europe formerly the uk's permanent
representative
to the eu in brussels ivan rogers
welcome to spectator tv thank you
for joining us just i know this is uh
difficult to answer but how
how would you assess the state of the
talks
as they stand well first of all thanks
very much for inviting me on
um look it's very fraught it's not
surprising it's fraught
um we're now coming to a crunch point
where real decisions have to be taken on
both sides
as to where the compromise is if there
is one
i don't think we're quite there yet uh
it's not been been moving very fast over
the last uh
few weeks i don't think it's moved very
fast this week
uh i think there'll be further
developments this weekend i would be
surprised if they weren't but i'm not
sure we are quite yet in the final
straight
my own view my own view is that you know
markets
and indeed some of the commentators at
this end have gone a little bit too
optimistic
markets are pricing in about a 75 to 80
chance of a deal i don't think it's
anything like that high
because i think a number of the issues
left on the table are extremely
difficult to solve
but it's not insoluble it is interesting
though the issues that's the
the real sticking points that seem to be
left on
on one side you've got state subsidies
you use that as a shorthand
and it's kind of interesting that a
conservative government
which is broadly meant to be against
state subsidies is kind of hanging out
for state subsidies
uh particularly since we use them a lot
less than even the germans
and on the eu side it's
fish particularly president macron which
is
important if you're in the fishing
industry but hardly central to the
future
of the eu or the united kingdom
yes although fish of course was a
massive issue on the way into the
european economic community in 1973 so
you know we've been here before
and on exit say the same issues arises
on
subsidies is an odd one i suppose what
the european side might say is this
isn't a classic
british conservative government yes
we've on the whole spent
far less in terms of state subsidies
than french or germans or other core
european members
and very deliberately so under both
conservative and labor governments i've
worked
for it's quite hard to argue obviously
we're in a different world postcovid
anyway in terms of what this government
would want to do and how it would want
to do it it's quite difficult if you
look at the
this government from a european
perspective to think of it as a classic
low tax low spend thatcherite government
it obviously isn't indeed
so i think there's nervousness not just
in the classic
old western european capitals uh paris
and berlin but also in eastern europe
and southern europe
about what the uk might do by way of
subsidies which sort of tilts the
playing field against their own
companies on their own market
uh as you we look back at the the the
talks
a lot of things jump out let me put two
that jumped out to me i'm sure you've
got many more one is it's pretty clear
to me
that the british never realized how
difficult it was going to be but
certainly the british politicians never
realized how difficult this was going
to be and another thing that does jump
out to me too is that
mr barnier and his team or maybe even
the eu as a whole
didn't quite clock the watershed
change for the negotiations that moving
from teresa may to the johnson
government
uh indicated symbolized
yeah i think that's right on both counts
um obviously when i was still there in
government in autumn 2016
an awful lot of ministers were not just
saying publicly that this was the
easiest trade negotiation in history but
they were saying that privately and they
thought it was the work of
months or perhaps weeks some were saying
days
and why did they think that because they
thought we were aligned on day one
because we'd been members for the last
45 years and therefore our rule book
was the same as the european rule book
and i kept on saying yes i understand
that but you've left
and you wanted to leave and you wanted
to leave presumably because you wanted
to divert
quite radically on that rulebook because
you didn't like being banned by that
rulebook
so the fact that you're convergent on
day one doesn't really make an awful lot
of difference to your negotiating
opposite numbers they want to know where
you want to be on day
two or day 200 or day 2000
and they assume you have some radically
different destination in mind otherwise
why would you have left
and i think we got caught up on that i
mean that took ages and it was a very
sterile debate within whitehall in 2016.
and we've
been caught up on that for a long time
then on the
difference between theresa may's version
of brexit and
boris johnson's look i i was very early
on saying
i mean pretty much from the point i
resigned if not before
the point i resigned i never thought
theresa may's version of brexit would
succeed because i didn't see how she
could get it through the house of
commons
she couldn't get it through her own
party and therefore unless she reached
out to the labour party and moderates in
the labour party and had a bipartisan
approach it was always going to fail
so i was privately saying to some old
friends on the european side of the
table
i know you think you sort of got there
with her with a deal which will fly but
i don't think it'll fly i think it'll
tank
then when it did tank it was less of a
shock of course by the time they've been
through
three or four iterations of her failing
in the house of commons
but then when johnson arrives he wants a
radically different version of brexit
because he wants it to be more
mid-atlantic more buccaneering and more
divergent
and it took then some time for them to
digest what that was
i think it took some time as well for
the british side to digest that
where they said they just wanted a bog
standard skinny free trade agreement
which looked a bit like canada
the other side was saying well actually
you want something deeper than canada on
multiple issues where the canadians
don't have a major trade relationship
with us
and therefore we're still going to apply
this benighted level playing field
conditionality to you
and that will be a scene aqua known for
a duty-free quota free deal
so yeah i mean i'm afraid this is a
history maybe you could say this is a
48-year history of misreadings of each
other's politics and incentives on both
sides
you could say it's a 400 year history
certainly the last four or five years
have been characterized by huge
misreadings on both sides of each
other's incentives i think
do you agree that even if we get a deal
that it won't be canada plus plus plus
we were talking on spectator tv last
week uh with the wolfgang muncher
formerly of the financial times yeah but
it's actually the best way to describe
is probably
canada dry dry yeah i think that's much
closer to the mark i mean in my little
book of about two years
ago i i made some jokes at the expense
of canada plus plus and said you know
beware of any deals with loads of pluses
in them
because the pluses are all the kinds of
things that you wanted in addition to
canada which the other side isn't
necessarily prepared to give you
so i think it would be pretty thin in
all honesty
i mean it won't be thin in terms of
volume it's still six or seven hundred
pages long what david frost is in the
presence of negotiating with michelle
buddy there's no such thing as a short
trade treaty i've never experienced such
a thing
but yes it won't be it'll be much
stronger obviously on goods than on
services that's essentially a british
choice
uh it's an interesting choice which
dates back you know many years
and we wanted to be divergent on
services it'll be thinner than i think
we could have negotiated and probably i
would have wanted to negotiate given a
free hand
but i always thought that we were
leaving the single market in the customs
union because
if you want to end free movement of
people and end budgetary contributions
and take back control of laws and
borders you are leaving the single
market
if you want to solve an autonomous trade
policy you can't be living in a customs
union
so i always thought we would end up with
a free trade agreement and said so
you know from june the 24th 2016 the
question is
what's the substance of the trade
agreement and how deep or how shallow do
you want to go
is there a possibility i don't wish to
frighten our viewers but is there a
possibility that these
negotiations never really end that
that if there is a deal the eu will make
it conditional by saying
all right you can have this kind of
state subsidy regime if that's what you
want we're not going to interfere
here it is on fishing here is on other
things but we the reserve the right
regularly to come back to see if you're
complying
with the spirit and the letter of our
deal and if you're not we will then
reopen the matter
or we will reduce the the
the uh openness of our market to use
well i think that's pretty inevitable i
mean let's say we get a deal and i hope
we do because i think it's a better
world than
a no deal world and no deal world is a
slightly
a world of purgatory because lots of
things ranging from you know road
haulage to electricity and gas to
aviation to fisheries in the end you
sooner or later have to sort in a legal
deal
so i don't think no deal is a terminus
you still have to solve things
what's going to happen then the uk is
going to say well we're sovereign and
autonomous and free now we want to do
our own thing in our own way and
legislating our own interests that's
obviously what a government will do what
the house of commons will do
they'll be occasions and i suspect
they'll be quite often where the
european union
side will say but hang on that's no
longer convergent with the same purposes
and delivering the same outcomes as as
we had agreed at the time we signed and
ratified the free trade agreement with
you
and if that's where you're going on this
bit of environmental legislation or
social legislation or taxation or
subsidy legislation
yes we will then retaliate
and remove market access and that's
indeed what they're discussing a lot in
the room at the moment the circumstances
under which you would be able to take
the other party to arbitration and
dispute resolution
and the circumstances in which you'd be
able to retaliate against each other
and what that retaliation what i know
the british side is very fearful of is
what the eu has frequently used against
switzerland over the last 25 years which
is sort of cross retaliation where they
can hit you where it hurts
outside the domain in which you've
allegedly committed the offense
i want to bring james in a second just
as we come to an end here but but
let me ask you another question let's
assume there's a deal
it's a bit scratchy the negotiations
don't quite go away but britain's uh
on its own off in some direction the eu
is there un encumbered now by the united
kingdom
what i've not been able to discern yet
is any kind of indication of what that
means
now for the eu without britain always
kind of holding them back
i i don't yet see a direction for the eu
uh a more integrated eu an eu that can
go
places that the british would have tried
to stop them either
coming out of paris or coming out of
berlin am i missing something
well i think there's one area in which
they've moved in a way they wouldn't
have been able to do had we been there
and that is the recovery package on
kovid
because they tied in that recovery
package which involves giving the
european commission
massive borrowing powers and raising the
so-called own resources ceiling
the amount of revenue that the union can
raise as a union
uh they've done that deal and tied it in
with their multi-annual financial
framework which is the jargon for their
seven year budget period
and frankly any government i ever worked
for would have vetoed that package
and because we weren't there also you're
quite clear that the british if we had
still been in
we would veto that we would have vetoed
that under any government i ever worked
for labor or conservative in my view
so that is a change well they would have
had we you know
where i came in in 2011 was when david
cameron tried
um essentially to stop the fiscal
compact treaty and deliver a quid pro
quo for the british side
via that treaty and the french and
germans decided to go around him
um and go via an intergovernmental
treaty outside the treaties and it's at
that point that he decides
they found a way around me and i'll have
to go for an in-out referendum
i've tried to tell that story in one or
two lectures i've given over recent
years
we would have done the same and said
this is not acceptable it's essentially
a eurozone fiscal package not a european
union one we don't accept a doubling of
the own resources ceiling or the
capacity for the european commission to
borrow on the markets
because the european commission is now
becoming a major borrower on the markets
on huge scale
i can't think of a british government i
work for that would have accepted that
so that's the one
area so far where you've seen a
development a big institutional
development where i think the european
union has done something or is in the
process of doing
something that it couldn't have done
without us
maybe they do some similar things on
defense where we were always the
blockage i personally was frequently the
blockage or
on preventing the union doing things
which we thought
contradicted what we wanted to do under
nato
the risk for us is obviously that on
both trade and financial services they
start behaving in a much more difficult
way which has impacts
negative impacts on us even though we're
outside the union
because the center of gravity of the
union has moved in a
in a less british and less anglo-saxon
[Music]
direction
[Music]
you